[Music]
a growing number of americans think
president biden's too liberal
and he's giving them trillions of
reasons to think that
the president getting ready to
supercharge his progressive agenda
with levels of spending we haven't seen
since world war
ii despite signs of runaway inflation
biden set to roll out a new six trillion
dollar budget plan
it includes big chunks of change for
things like infrastructure
education and fighting climate change
biden's in ohio today boasting about the
economy and taking shots at republicans
this is our moment to rebuild an economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
not a trickle-down economy every time i
talk about
tax cuts for working-class people oh my
god
what are we going to do well we're going
to take back some of that one percent
money even my republican friends in
congress
not a single one of them voted for the
rescue plan
i'm not going to embarrass any one of
them but i have
here a list
of how back in their districts they're
bragging about
the rescue plan i mean some people have
no shame
as for the president's agenda 46 percent
of americans say biden's too liberal
and that's up 10 from december 2019
when he was running as a moderate and
dana i checked the internals the
partisan breakdown
is good i approve of that poll so you
can thank goodness for that
take that to the bank what did you think
of biden out there
getting out of the white house going to
ohio and trying to sell
6 trillion he's going to have to do a
lot of selling because
the longer this infrastructure bill sits
out there without a deal
while he is planning on additional
spending
you have to start asking yourself then
what problem are you trying to solve the
republicans have come forward and said
look
you went from 2.3 to 1.7 we're offering
you 1.05 and we're going we want to use
all this unspent coveted money
which i think to a lot of people makes a
lot of sense but if if
we also have to deal with in the
possibility of an inflation uh ed
lawrence was just on a fox or in the
previous hour
talking about how if you're gonna have a
barbecue this weekend there's all these
products that are
costing a lot more including meat for
example
and that's what everybody's buying that
the housing market you have
very inflated prices and so that's
boxing younger people out of buying
homes
and they're all these real problems and
it is okay
i want the administration should know
that it's okay to take
the autopilot off and fly the plane
yourself when there are changing
conditions now he's out there saying how
great the economy is but he wants to
spend all this money to fix the economy
when all of these flashing yellow lights
are like well wait a second maybe we
don't need
that particular help i think on the
moderate thing that he's or a moderate
liberal
it's interesting because they definitely
hid behind
the moderate claim during the election
but then as soon as he was elected
he was like well why are you surprised
this is what i said i was going to do
during the campaign but remember because
the campaign was what it was
they didn't cover anything there was
nothing to cover so
some people seem a little bit surprised
but that 46 number
10 since january as covet isn't
it continues to get a little further in
the rear view mirror
i think that that number could probably
go higher and the next 100 days for him
is going to be pretty tough
i agree that that number his moderate
mantle just got blown out of the water
and it's because 6 trillion geraldo i
mean that's an alimony payment for you
but for most people they look at 6
trillion
and they say wow i've never had an
ex-wife say anything bad about me
you have to get to pay so when you when
you
do you think normal americans are
looking at six trillion does that does
that register
i don't think so i i really don't think
so i think there when you look at
biden's popularity
he's in the mid 50s that means most
americans you know the country's divided
anyway most americans want the rich to
pay more taxes
most americans want corporations to pay
more taxes uh you know he's a
he's a nice guy a soft sell he came here
to cleveland today
you know he uh he cheered uh everyone
getting vaccinated he cheered our
state's maximilian contest uh you know a
nice lady from southwest ohio won
a kid got a full scholarship to a state
school so he toured the tech side of it
and uh basically a soap the rich uh
platform
for a democrat in the early stages of
his first term is not
bad uh strategy i i think that uh you
know he's doing okay
what's the difference between 1.9
trillion and a
1.1 trillion you know uh if if it's more
than a hundred dollars a thousand
dollars uh
you know these numbers are so
astronomical we can't even conceive of
that
but uh you know in summary i think that
uh he's doing okay and that this plan
uh you know the build back better uh if
he can stick to
highways and bridges and internet and
you know some of the things people
understand and not
but that's the pork barrel stuff but i
think it'll be fine yeah but
greg to geraldo's point you know you can
soak the rich but if you add trillions
in spending to that
you you jack up inflation and the people
that aren't rich
are certain they're gonna feel pinched
yeah that's the
that's a disincentive that that the
democrats ignore
the sad reality is is that small
government
isn't just dead small government is dead
and we're abusing the corpse
i mean this is like this that's why
you're right nobody understands these
numbers
it is gross it makes me sick to my
stomach look the campaign strategy that
biden had is the same strategy he has
now
uh as a president the key feature is
no transparency everything the white
house does
is meant to prevent you from seeing how
hard left
the mission has become it's the opposite
of the previous boss
whether you like trump or you hated him
he did everything
in front of you joe is more like a paid
spokesman for an infomercial for a
product that you never actually
see and then you get to this poll right
which
which proves this amazing point in polls
of like liberal perception
it's presented as a negative when you
were seen as too liberal
liberal even by the liberals that if you
say hey look at this he's really liberal
no no no no no they can't even be they
can't even afford to be seen
as a purer version of their own ideology
which tells you two things one liberals
could liberalism could only be tolerated
in small doses
it's kind of a like it's kind of like
whipped cream on ice cream and
they need to lie about their depth of
liberalism in order to survive
so joe biden is kind of like the old
west
movie sets geraldo knows what i'm
talking about where the banks and the
hotels are simply one-dimensional
but behind it something else is going on
and it's aoc
and it's wokism it's not the trillion
dollar stuff that scares me it's the
wokism
that's coming out speaking of ice cream
dr sapphire
the president got a scoop or two today
and the big question was
what flavor was it from the media i mean
he could just coast on stuff like that
he never has to
reveal what greg was saying what's going
on behind the scenes
i'm going to bet that it was vanilla if
i know president biden at all at this
point it's probably vanilla just a very
flat vanilla but
you know a couple points that i want to
make on this first of all when you have
like larry summers the
the obama clinton official warning about
some of the
the rise in minimum wage and the
regulation and the support of the unions
saying that that could you obviously
lead to a very large inflation
i listen when you have like the allen
greenwald
saying that what president biden
recently did with the waiver of
intellectual property rights causing
businesses to quickly raise their prices
i mean i'm going to listen to these
people they know what they're talking
about
but one point that i did notice from
what president biden was saying
what happened to that unity that
bipartisan unity he goes up there
and like a child holds up a list of
republicans names saying that they were
bragging and touting
i looked some of those up you know rep
mccarthy the one that he said he was
bragging about it
rep mccarthy just posted the link for
small businesses
in his district to get financial help he
said i didn't vote for this
because i didn't agree for with
everything in it but that doesn't mean
that i don't want support
for our small businesses so i actually
think that this continues
this verbiage is continuing to create
that division that i think most people
voted for president biden because they
didn't want anymore
so you're saying the president might be
being a little dishonest
wow i am shocked to hear that well
i'm not sure politician not jesse
i've never heard that before hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else